في ملف الاحتجاجات التي تشهدها ايران قال
المفوض السامي حقوق الانسان في الامم
المتحده فولكيراتور كائن 14 الف شخص بينهم
اطفال يعتقل في ايران خلال هذه الاحتجاج
حقوق الانسان تحت عنوان تدهور وضع حقوق
الانسان بعد الاحتجاجات الاخيره قال تركي
ان الامم المتحده طلبت من السلطات
الايرانيه زياره البلاد لكنها لم تتلقى اي
رد ودعا الى وضع حدا لما وصفه بالاستخدام
غير الضروري وغير المتناسب للقوه
كان هناك ازمه شامله لحقوق الانسان في
ايران معربا عن قلقه مما وصفها بالزياده
مقلقه لعمليه الاعدامه في المقابل قالت
ممثله ايران في المجلس من الدول الغربيه
تفتقد الى الصدقيه الاخلاق
من جانبيه اعلنا مدير الدائره الامنيه في
محافظتك كردستان غربي ايران محمد رضا مقتل
احد افراد قوات التعبئه الفاسيج امس
الاربعاء في مدينه ماريان بالمحافظه
لاطلاق الرصاص من شخص مجهول مشيرا الى ان
تحقيقات جاريه لالقاء القبض على الفاعل
شهدت خلال الايام الماضيه تجمعات احتجاجك
لو كانت وكاله انباء فارس الايراني قد
افادت ان استخبارات الحرس الثوري اعتقلت
مواطنا بريطانيا من اصول ايرانيه في مدينه
اصفهان وسط البلاد
التعاون مع قناتي بي بي سي الفارسيه
وايران انترناشونال والتحريض على العصيان
المدني واعمال
وتخريب الممتلكات العامه خلال الاحتجاجات
في البلاد منذ اكثر من شهرين وارتباطه
بعناصر معاديه اذن لايران خارج البلاد حسب
تعبيره الوكاله
باسم السلطه القضائيه الايرانيه اعلن
الثلاثاء الماضي اعتقال 40 اجنبيا قال ان
لهم دورا في الاحتجاجات